cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
most people don't pay attention at all
no they don't yeah they don't it's
they're sheep and I keep saying we got
to wake up the Lions but this is why you
were telling us before the show that uh
they kicked you out of Hollywood because
you're conservative yeah but this is
exactly why I mean you have the biggest
show in the world the last thing they
need is someone as influential as you
speaking to the regular people who
aren't paying attention and telling them
to pay attention right that's dangerous
what did you do what did you say that
people I think you know the whole
internet thing started in the mid 90s
right You've Got Mail and it just kind
of Grew From there so I was starting to
do my own thing talking about this how
about that so oh my gosh he's a
Christian and a conservative so
apparently that's a double leper in
Hollywood and uh they called me in and
they said we can't work it anymore and I
laughed I said you guys are the ones
screaming for tolerance and they scream
for freedom of speech but we all know
it's a one-way street with these guys
and once again hypocrisy rules not only
Hollywood and Washington DC so I form
sobelstudios.com and I've been doing my
own movies since and because I do
independent movies other end of
dependent Movie Makers come to me as
well not every movie I've done because
since I got booted in Hollywood I shot
about 50 movies but there's other Indies
that come to me and say hey we we're
with you we stand with you people used
to stop me all the time about Hercules
and Andromeda my two series eighty
percent time now it's God's Not Dead
Soul Surfer what if let there be light
that's what people stop me for now
please make more movies like that yeah
when this happened initially in
Hollywood where was the the biggest
amount of pressure coming from was it
coming from Studio heads was it coming
from Agents and managers why was it
coming from other apps I didn't get
details like that but I it it got to a
point that obviously they felt they'd
talk to me about something it was coming
from Studios and networks and stuff like
that so they they saw it as uh as bad
publicity for them yeah I think so which
is weird because like at that time we're
talking uh 12 12 years ago this is still
a country that would have had a general
amount of of pro-christian values yeah
my manager was great I think she just
felt the pressure and it went along with
went along with the big agent so it's
unfortunate and uh I I kind of laughed
at I said this is ridiculous but uh you
know for for an industry that's
these liberals need to look up the
definition of the word liberal because
the whole thing about being a liberal is
that everybody's point of view is okay
we're different we Embrace everybody
they don't we have more anger more
hatred all this stuff is just spreading
more divisiveness and that's the world
we're living in right now this is what
wokeness tends to be right right now
they masquerade as opposing racism while
supporting racial segregation they say
liberal when they're illiberal they
oppose liberal policies and classical
liberals what's antifa they say they're
against fascism they're actually the
fascists but here's the funny thing is
they always love it's it they it is it
is a fair assessment in my opinion if
you look at antifa through a historical
context by today by what they what they
do today and say they're fascists antifa
starts in Germany as the melted wing of
the Communist party and so they go the
we're not fascist but now you take a
look at how they behave there were a
group of people outside of a hospital
protesting Mass mandates antifa
activists came and said beating them up
so it's like okay if you want to claim
to be a communist or opposing fascism
but you beat people up to enforce
government mandated corporate activities
you're a fascist that's exactly what
they are I just don't understand these
Mayors and these governors in these
states let them get away with it I don't
I don't get it because they're right on
at all yeah well they have to be I mean
you've had politicians say that they're
antifa you've had uh you had in the uh
and you know but I said it was an idea
yeah a Nadler that was I think that was
Network did Biden say it too I know you
said it in the in the debate against
with Trump wow he said oh it's an idea
oh okay because it's decentralized
therefore you can't you can't pinpoint a
leader burn down people's businesses and
attack people that's an idea you can
pinpoint leaders they have they have
active cells with brand names and brand
websites and the FEDS know and the FEDS
don't do anything but hey man heaven
forbid you stepped on the grass on
January 6 and then they're going to lock
you up for two years Biden's quote from
that presidential debate in 2020 was
antifa is an idea not an organization so
I was gonna agree
it is an idea but it's also an
organization but that's hard to buy it
and you just said it was well that's
what I like Mass because they cover
their identity they have chapters in
merch stores it's absolutely but the
masks don't even matter you can go to
there there's different chapters and
they will call themselves brand antifa
you know insert name and you can go to
their website you can see the organizers
what do they do for work oh a lot of
these kids are rich yeah do you think so
I know for a fact wow yeah so especially
during Occupy Wall Street we didn't call
them antifa at the time they're just
called the black block anarchists and
that was an unfair assessment the
anarchist got mad at us they were like
those guys are not anarchists anarchists
don't believe in violence anarchists in
the truest sense of left or right
believe in non-aggression so the dudes
wearing all black going and beating
people are tankies are communists and
we're like oh okay you know that's fair
but we didn't call them antifa turns out
a lot of these kids were they're like
brooklynite trust fund kids really they
hate their parents yeah they don't have
to work yeah how how do you how so
they're they're they're they're angry
because their parents made it in the
capitalist system and
they're angry because
so it's it's an oversimplification that
I believe is is an emotional attack that
conservatives will be like oh they
resent you know they got mommy or daddy
issues no the reality is they've never
dealt with hardship so if you grow up in
a world where you don't have to work
because things are given to you when
you're older you look around at people
being hungry and you go why aren't
people giving them things like I was
given things the government should give
them things give them homes and this is
why you know I I really man I see a lot
of a lot of wealthy conservatives being
like my kids never gonna know the
hardship I knew and I'm like okay well
then be a liberal then because they're
gonna look at Murdoch's kids right and
they're gonna look what they're doing at
Fox and you're gonna send them to the to
the same four-year colleges that will
indoctrinate them in the same way they
started kindergarten now unfortunately
but but if you're lucky enough to keep
it off them until until they go to
college they then go to college and they
end up in the exact same place because
you don't want them to face down any of
the hardships these these these trust
fund kids especially the the wealthier
ones and and not necessarily all
millionaires or anything but coming from
upper middle class families even so they
didn't have to work because they lived
with their parents their their attitude
is you know we've we have to we have we
have to protect the oppressed it's
weaponizing and so what happens is when
they don't want to be the evil oppressor
because they come from wealthy
upbringing they turn into a racial issue
they can then say oh yeah you you're you
Ian you're also an oppressor just like
me because you're white and it's like
you know you could you could be a
homeless white dude and they would be it
doesn't matter we're all oppressors it's
like bro your your parents are
millionaires that homeless guy was a is
a veteran who can't find work and you're
claiming that he's at the same level of
power that you do because they're trying
to cover up the fact that they're rich
and they want more power but ultimately
what are they angry about
when you grow up never having to work
your brain does not comprehend where
food comes from your brain doesn't
comprehend that someone has to do labor
to make it and so in their minds it's
just like you take a look at uh schools
a lot of these kids they go to school
from uh you know kindergarten all the
way till they're 22 to 26 and when they
get out of college at 26 years old
they've never had a job and they've been
told how to do everything normal humans
have to figure things out yeah but these
kids are told to do they get out and
they're like okay someone please tell me
what to do I have no idea what happened
they get their first job and the you'll
they find that the employers say that
they're that they can't figure things
out on their own they need to be given
step-by-step instructions because
they've never actually had to kind of
they never saw the problem they've never
problem solved anything I've experienced
this uh dozens of times in every company
I've worked for college graduates have a
higher uh likelihood of being unable to
solve a problem as opposed to high
school graduates or dropouts
homeschoolers are much better that's
true Did you homeschool were you
homeschooled my own my wife's homeschool
Advocates she's got a number of books on
she travels the country and uh yeah it
makes a big difference one of the
blessings of covid is that families woke
up and saw maybe honey we shouldn't use
the public schools as a babysitting
service yes and they sound crappy that
the school system really is two million
more homes are now homeschooling which
is great and school choice is picking up
I know I know there's some pushback from
some anti-woke personalities but I think
school choice for the most part is a
good idea on its face it looks cool that
you could take a stipend every year
instead of send them to where you have
to send them you get to pick where you
want to send them right great
competition get it out of government's
hands but that will create the
competition now that should help a
little bit but Public School Systems
busted and broken and it's getting worse
and people don't seem to want to care
and parents want to keep using it as a
babysitting service which is too bad oh
you've made a good point that people are
waking up shocked so many people talking
about this look what they did to these
kids you know I mean it's not look at
the businesses it was it was nuts I was
arguing with someone I never get into I
never get political arguments online
it's like the last thing I do I was
arguing with someone saying that like
there should be
class there should be cameras in every
classroom I've said the same thing a
hundred times right why can't I mean
people are saying especially pro pro
teachers union people saying that's not
necessary why would that be necessary
like do you think cops should have to
wear body cameras the the cops didn't
think that they should have to wear body
cameras cameras Everest cameras and
casinos and cameras and elevators why
can't they be in a school what what are
they hiding that we can't watch as
parents I mean not even just that but
beyond beyond just what they're hiding
I'm on camera all the time the level of
what they're teaching the kids right the
parents have a right to know uh at what
pace their classrooms are working not
just because they might be teaching them
things that are not that is
inappropriate for their age but also
like are the teachers keeping them up to
date are they classrooms actually be
handled well and those are all questions
but they don't want to actually be held
accountable for that yeah well there do
it was when the remote learning started
yeah that these teachers there was a
video where they were saying we can't
let parents find out what we're doing
they know what they're doing is crooked
evil they aren't even right now I just
realized that the Apple's watching
the crazy thing is I was uh somebody was
talking about how
the iPhone does this I don't know if
this is true just this caveat here
because I haven't looked it up but
well let me let me pause I had a phone
it was um I forgot what the phone was
called I think it was like the McLaren
something it was like a one phone and it
had a mechanical front-facing camera in
order to uh turn the front-facing camera
on it would slide up from the top of the
phone okay so one day
while browsing the web it just opens up
and then goes back down
and I'm like why did this website just
activate my front-facing camera and then
deactivate my front-facing camera now on
most phones you can't tell because the
front-facing camera is just always
always there staring at you yeah but
various websites so what someone was
saying is that iPhones for instance when
you're using their apps will take a
picture of your face to see your
reaction whether you're happy sad upset
what's your emotional state because the
AI can track your facial expressions so
when you're using apps it's reading your
face to see how you doing
yeah I got I got buddy swears that
Oliver TV sets have cameras in they're
watching us in our living rooms in our
bedrooms I don't know if they have
cameras they I don't they have
microphones and the microphones are all
recording you 24 7. that's a fact so uh
for instance we have we have a TV
downstairs that can be terrible yeah so
uh first caveat not all TVs but all
modern TVs that have voice command are
recording you 24 7. because here's how
it works and this is true of all your at
home devices and to a certain degree I
believe many of your phones if you're if
your electronic device has a voice
command that means the microphone has to
be listening to you all the time so that
when you speak the command it turns on
yeah now how does it translate your your
speech into into a command it records
what you say sends it to a private
company who then transcribes it to text
sends the text code back to the app the
app then runs the code the speech as the
action
that means and not every single device
but most devices that have voice
activation do it this way some do it by
requiring you to say a phrase three or
three to five times and then it just
uses the wavelength to try and match
them we don't really do that anymore
nowadays yeah they're just all on all
the time recording everything you say
and uh for your at-home device that does
all little Deeds for you there have been
numerous stories where murders have
taken place and the police have gotten
recordings of the murder from the
company who owned the device
and then they said oh you know they
don't normally record it was a fluke
here thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time